der anker stich findet beim bau von
verankerungen und einer bergrettung
verwendung
es wird eine schlaufe gebildet meistens
verwendet man die mitte des saales bzw
der rebschnitt oder der band schlinge um
diesen knoten zweckmäßig verwenden zu
können
das seil wird mit der schlaufe umwickelt
dienten der rebschnitt beziehungsweise
des seiles werden durch die schlaufe
gezogen
die rebsch nur beziehungsweise das seil
wird einmal um den anschlag punkt gelegt
überkreuzt und gegen gleich
zurückgeführt
beide seite strenge laufen
auf gleicher seite aus
eine knick belastung muss vermieden
werden da es die buch las des materials
wesentlich verringert